-Welcome to "The Tonight Show,"
everybody.
Thank you so much for watching.
Peaceful protests continued
throughout the country
this weekend.
All ages,
all races participating,
which should give us all hope.
And I think politicians are
hearing the message
loud and clear, which goes to
show you how powerful
letting your voice
being heard is.
So let's get to
some news and some jokes.
Well, guys, it feels like
we are living through
some of the craziest times ever.
Good news -- there's a new poll
out today to confirm it.
-A new NBC News/Wall Street
Journal poll finds 80% of voters
feel that our country
is out of control.
-Yeah, if we hit
90% out of control,
every American gets
their own show on Bravo, so...
That's right, 80% think
the country is out of control.
Right now America is somewhere
between Trump's Twitter page
and J.K. Rowling's Twitter page.
Even crazier, 15% of people
think that things
are under control.
Yeah.
When the Titanic was going down,
these were the people who were
trying to get
a drink at the bar.
"It's fine.
Can I just get a gin and tonic?
It's a boat. What do boats do,
right? They float."
Here's some cool news.
Yesterday Senator Mitt Romney
decided to march with
protesters.
Man, you know you're starting to
reach white people
when you get the whitest
of all white people.
-We need a voice
against racism.
We need many voices against
racism and against brutality.
We need to stand up and say
that black lives matter.
-When Mitt was spotted walking
with thousands of people,
everyone just thought he was
taking his family to lunch.
That's right --
Mitt Romney marched with
Black Lives Matter protesters.
That's like seeing
the Wu-Tang Clan
show up at a Kenny G concert.
Yesterday on CNN, former
Secretary of State Colin Powell
shared his reasons for not
supporting President Trump.
-One word I have to use with
respect to what he's doing
for the last several years is
a word I would never have used
before, I never would have used
with any of the four presidents
I've worked for -- he lies.
He lies about things.
-Apparently after upsetting
black people
and military leaders,
Trump decided
let's just roll it all into one.
Meanwhile, in response to calls
from prominent NFL players,
Commissioner Roger Goodell
released a statement
over the weekend apologizing
on behalf of the league
for not listening
to players earlier. Take a look.
-We, the National Football
League, admit we were wrong for
not listening to NFL players
earlier and encourage all
to speak out
and peacefully protest.
-You could tell
Goodell was nervous 'cause
I think he delivered that
from his underground bunker.
That's right. The NFL feels so
badly that they're this close
to scheduling another fake
workout for Colin Kaepernick.
Here's a fun fact.
I just said Colin Kaepernick's
name one more time
than Roger Goodell did.
Well, after hearing
all the news,
I know things seem
pretty volatile right now,
but don't worry.
The President has a plan.
-We are learning the White House
is seriously considering
having President Trump give
a speech on race this week.
-Apparently Trump wants to get
those "country out of control"
numbers up to 100%
by this weekend.
Trump is thinking about giving a
big nationally televised speech
about race and unity
that's currently being written
by six white guys named Dale.
Yeah, on Thursday we'll hear
a nationally televised speech
about race and unity,
and on Friday,
we'll hear an apology speech for
what he said on Thursday.
Trump is giving a speech
about race and unity.
It will be like listening
to a lecture
on veganism from Joey Chestnut.
For those of you who don't know
the competitive hot dog eating
and digesting world,
Joey Chestnut is the champ.
Anyway.
If Trump gives
a national address,
it will be broadcast on
all major television networks,
plus you can watch it on B.E.T.
with a laugh track.
Trump may give an address
on race and unity.
Then after that, J.K. Rowling
will give her thoughts
on the transgender community.
Right now, Trump's giving the
unity speech a lot of thought.
He's trying to decide if he
should deliver it from behind
the new White House fence or
inside his underground bunker.
That's right. Staffers
are a little worried about
Trump's speech 'cause he wants
to talk about all the progress
that he's made in Wakanda.
Hey, here's some good news.
New York City started partially
reopening today.
-We're celebrating, we're back,
we're reopening, we're excited.
Our mojo's back.
-Yeah, New York began phase one
of its reopening plan today.
Phase two is
restaurants and bars.
Then after everyone packs
restaurants and bars,
phase three is another
three months of quarantine.
It's not just New York City.
Las Vegas has reopened too.
Casinos said safety is
their number-one priority
then went back to
letting everyone smoke
while they play craps.
That's right. Vegas is open,
but temperature checks
are required at hotels.
Security will be like,
"Either he has coronavirus
or he just lost 50 grand
and is about to tell his wife."
That is our monologue,
everybody.